a weak government desperate to show its
strength days after a failed coup
attempt a demonstration of support to
Mark a year since the military took
power in Bina Faso the instigators of
the coup will have to walk over our dead
bodies first on Tuesday prover
protesters taking to the streets of
wagadugu after being awoken to sound of
gunfire from several military camps
initially the Juna said it was a
training exercise only later releasing
this statement on National Television
acknowledging the attempt to destabilize
the young regime four senior officers
from the special forces and the police
have been arrested another two are on
the
Run anger is growing in the ranks since
the beginning of the year at least 6,000
people have been killed in attacks by
alqaeda and isil Affiliates most of them
sold soldiers when TR seized control he
promised to restore Security in Bina
Faso but by his own admission the Army
has lost control of 2third of a country
the size of the United Kingdom two armed
groups his supporters hold signs
condemning sanctions imposed by the
regional body echos and its backers
France and the EU the increasingly
isolated Jinta is in search of other
partners
in early September neighboring Mali and
ner signed a Joint Defense pact part
contract the Contracting parties will
work to prevent manage and resolve any
armed Rebellion or other threat to the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
each of the member countries of the
alliance giving priority to peaceful and
diplomatic means and if necessary to the
use of force to deal with situations of
breach of peace and
stability despite this demonstration
celebrating Bina faso's Jun unity in the
ranks and Trust in the leadership appear
to be crumbling Nicholas Hawk Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz